à présent s'intéresse Michael à cette
opération de contrôle de la répression
des fraudes dans un supermarché de
sensir sur Loire en réponse à la
mobilisation des agriculteurs le
ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire a
annoncé fin janvier le doublement des
contrôles du respect de la
réglementation par les distributeurs et
les industriels en andréloir la
direction générale de la concurrence de
la consommation et de la répression des
fraudes a déjà intensifier ses
opérations hier l'un de ses agents a
réalisé une inspection dans un
supermarché c'est le supermarché au
champ de saint-ciier surloire Faustine
luno et la turquy on va commencer par
les bananes et les chiwiis ok vous avez
des bananes des antifrançaises aussi non
on a changé Diana peut-être ça dépend
des arrivages d'accord ces opérations de
contrôle les grandes surfaces en font
l'objet plusieurs fois par an chaque
fois c'est une surprise car le magasin
n'est jamais prévenu à l'avance les
commerçants y sont habitués mais
toujours un peu stressés oui je
comprends je comprends effectivement il
il y a des abus qui ont été fait donc
c'est normal qu' a des contrôles depuis
que je suis sur le magasin je n'ai pas
eu de problème mais effectivement il
peut y avoir des des erreurs humaines
mais sur le magasin en tout cas on l'a
jamais eu en André Loir 1 inspecteurs de
la concurrence de la consommation et de
la répression des fraud qui doivent
rester anonymes sont régulièrement sur
le terrain aujourd'hui ils cible en
particulier la viande et les fruits et
légumes VO ah oui le marquage il est sur
le côté sur côté tu voir
France ça c'est les bar
ça c'est l'evrac calibre ça c'est
l'evrac d'accord France voilà donc c'est
bien spécifier on vérifie si les
informations qui sont délivrées au
consommateur par voie d'affichage sont
exactes par rapport à ce qu'il y a
effectivement écrit sur l'emballage ou
si c'est du vrac sur les factures c'est
important parce que c'est une
information déterminante pour pour le
consommateur et et qui peut en fait le
pousser à acheter un kiwi plutôt qu'un
autre des contrôles que le gouvern a
promis aux agriculteurs d'intensifier en
indréloir c'est déjà le cas ils ont été
doublés entre 2021 et 2023 on voit pas
mal de contrôle de d'agriculteur en ce
moment et moi je souhaite montrer que
l'État aussi contrôle et ce que je
souhaite montrer c'est que il a pas
attendu cette crise pour contrôler on
est vraiment attentif à cette
problématique par exemple en 2023 il y a
eu 4 PV de rédigé
donc avec des distributeurs ou des
industries agroalimentaires ou des
grossistes qui peuvent être sanctionné
en cas d'anomalie la sanction est
proportionnée et peut aller du simple
avertissement à une amende salée voire
une peine d'emprisonnement ici rien à
signaler pour le moment mais le contrôle
n'est pas terminé il faudra encore
effectuer une vérification avec les
factures fournies par le
magasin
y